es gibt ein tabu thema über das in
deutschland nicht viel gesprochen wird
sexueller missbrauch im sport in diesem
film werden uns zwei betroffene ihre
geschichten erzählen und sie sind keine
einzelfälle
wissenschaftlerinnen gehen von insgesamt
200.000 fällen in den letzten
jahrzehnten in deutschland aus wenn
vereine nicht richtig aufpassen kann
jeder trainer werden auch
sexualstraftäter
wie kann das sein
[Musik]
jakob war neun als er von seinem
fußballtrainer missbraucht wurde heute
mit 17 spricht er zum ersten mal
öffentlich darüber weil er anderen mut
machen und dann hat uns der trainer hat
gefragt ob sie bei ihm übernachten
wollen und dann halt zum abend hin zum
abend hin hat er sich halt dann
ausgezogen und wir mussten das auch ja
und dann musste ich halt sein glied
anfassen ja trainiert und dann hat er
auch mainz angefasst ja und dann ich
habe halt angst total gehabt er hat mir
gedroht um das auch sehr aggressiv dass
ich dann halt vom fußball dass ich dann
nicht mehr dabei bin und fußball war
immer meine sache mir auch sehr am
herzen gelegen dass das der neunjährige
reagiert wie viele kinder reagieren
er zieht sich zurück wird aggressiv
wehrt ab jakobs mutter spürt dass etwas
nicht stimmt sie spricht ihn mehrfach an
bleibt aber ratlos
dass es mit dem fußball und dem trainer
zusammenhängen könnte war für sie nicht
vorstellbar er hat sich erst mal mit uns
angefreundet und hat auch starkes
engagement mit zeiten hat sich an also
wirklich für den verein und fußball
richtig gut eingesetzt
dieser mann konto ist dementsprechend
auch mit seiner persönlichkeit perfekt
täuschen und deshalb sind wir auch als
eltern darauf reingefallen und hatte
überhaupt gar keine chance sie zu sehen
dass dieser mann wirklich eine art täter
ist
was dem verein vorher nicht bekannt war
der täter war bereits wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs eines kindes vorbestraft wie
war es möglich dass dieser mann trainer
wurde
fest steht jacob ist kein einzelfall
forscherinnen der universität ulm
schätzen etwa 200.000 menschen mussten
in den letzten jahrzehnten sexuelle
gewalt im sport erleben ähnlich viele
wie in den kirchen dh die dimension ist
eigentlich riesig ist genauso groß
mindestens genauso groß wie in den
kirchen und die fälle sind wirklich da
also ich würde nie ein skandal
herbeirufen sondern der alltägliche
missbrauch ist der skandal und mit dem
müssen wir umgehen
laut der studie sex bord halten gerade
mal die hälfte der vereine in
deutschland die prävention
sexualisierter gewalt für ein relevantes
thema und ein kinder schutz beauftragten
hat nur jeder zehnte verein was vereine
tun könnten zeigt der sv buchholz in
berlin
sie haben ja charlott mit seinem
bundesweit einzigartigen projekt kleine
helden eingeladen
er zeigt wie sich kinder selbstbewusst
wehren können auch gegen übergriffe und
sexuelle gewalt
wer heute kein tor geschossen hat der
muss mir nachher unter der dusche wenn
wir alle zusammen den rücken schrubben
ist okay aber der sagt wird machen die
internationalen hause ist dann okay
werdet die nationale macht ja was sage
ich dann wirklich in ihrer situation
mache ich nicht und dann wenn man es
dann gesagt hat mache ich nicht und da
sagten ja wir hätten da für dich oder
wie jetzt dann weiter jetzt ist ja also
ja ich werde ja ihr müsstet unbedingt
müssen dort andere erfahren der beste
schutz für kinder in täter strategien
erklären und sie stark machen
mit stimme und körper
[Applaus]
auch mathilde erzählt uns ihre
geschichte mit 13 erlebte sie schwere
sexuelle gewalt sie bleibt zunächst
stumm schreibt alles in ihr tagebuch
auch 20 jahre danach kämpft sie noch mit
panikattacken und hat lebenslänglich und
es ist es wie in seen wortmann man
verliert so viel und es dauert ewig bis
man überhaupt ein bisschen wieder zu
sich kommt und seine gefühle entdecken
kann weil man es wirklich versteinert
und das ist leider für immer
sie ist eine der besten spielerinnen in
ihrem verein am abend eines auswärts
turniers durch sie und dann steht
plötzlich ihr hilfs trainer im raum
ich war so ein schockzustand ich konnte
nicht schreien und ich konnte mich auch
nicht wären also ich war da war ich wie
so ein gegenstand sozusagen also ich
habe das irgendwie durchgehalten und als
er fertig war lag ich dann rum das
verteilt weil das war in diesen
duschraum sie wird vergewaltigt
der täter fährt sie am nächsten tag
sogar noch nach hause monatelang fühlt
sie nichts als ohnmacht bis sie es nicht
mehr ertragen kann
sie verlässt ihr heimatdorf geht nach
berlin und macht zwei traumatherapie
dennoch das erlebte kann sie kaum
verarbeiten bis vor einem jahr habe ich
mir für alles die schuld gegeben auch
wir hätten ja ich denke ich auch ein
ganz anderes leben führen können also
ich hätte auch gerne studiert ich wäre
auch gerne mehr unter menschen und würde
was schaffen aber man ist so blockiert
aber diese scham und schuldgefühle die
zerstören ein oft aber heute 20 jahre
später ist die tat verjährt aber sie
will es öffentlich machen und wendet
sich an die kommission zur aufarbeitung
sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs
der missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung johannes wilhelm röhrig
beklagt dass im sport noch zu wenig zum
schutz der kinder getan wird
deswegen bin ich für einen pakt gegen
sexuellen missbrauch im sport in dem
jeder verein den beschluss trifft den
pakt beizutreten fortbildung für alle
trainerinnen und trainer zu dem
themenfeld und alle erwachsenen
anzubieten beispielsweise elternabende
durchzuführen und auch über die folgen
von missbrauch und wie missbrauch
entsteht und die perfiden täter
strategien ausgestaltet sind dass
darüber alle informiert sind macht
ausüben und vertrauen missbrauchen
diese strategie verfolgte jacobs trainer
erst als ein mitspieler von jakob sein
schweigen bricht offenbart er sich
seinen eltern und machte eine aussage
bei der polizei
doch es dauert mehr als ein jahr bis es
zur anklage gegen den fußballtrainer
kommt währenddessen bleibt der täter auf
freiem fuß und wohnt nur 300 meter
entfernt
der weg zum fußballplatz war auch immer
da wo sein haus oder eine wohnung war
und jedesmal sich da vorbeigefahren bin
halt alles wieder hochgekommen habe ich
auch wieder total angst jakob war nicht
der einzige
drei weitere junge aus dem sc müssingen
mussten ähnliches durchmachen
welche verantwortung trägt der
fußballverein
wir versuchen uns gespräch zu kommen
doch der verein will kein interview
geben
in einer schriftlichen stellungnahme
teilt er uns mit wie kinder jetzt besser
geschützt werden sollen
durch regelmäßige informationen
präventions- trainings und einen
kinderschutz beauftragten schriftlich
heißt es zitat alle übungsleiter denn
und trainerinnen werden regelmäßig zur
vorlage eines aktuellen erweiterten
führungszeugnisses aufgefordert mit
zukünftigen übungs leitenden wird der
arbeitsvertrag erst ausgehändigt wenn
ein aktuelles erweitertes
führungszeugnis vorliegt
erweiterte führungszeugnisse für ihren
amtliche trainer für jacobs ehemaligen
verein ein konsequenter schritt wenn
auch im fall von jakob zu spät noch zu
wenige sportvereine verlangen dies sie
befürchten dass dein ehrenamtliche
wegbleiben
wir fragen nach beim
bundesinnenministerium das ist für den
spitzensport zuständig dort soll es
künftig verbindliche regeln für die
nutzung erweiterte führungszeugnisse
geben
warum geht das nicht auch im
breitensport das ist ein juristisch ganz
schwieriges thema weil sie mit dem
artikel neuen grundgesetz eine eine
sogenannte vereins und verbandsautonomie
haben die gesetzliche eingriffe in das
selbstorganisation sind das freiheits
organisations reicht von bürgern die
sich in vereinen organisieren dürfen
immer unter einem
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz sitzen
müssen
man müsste also das grundgesetz ändern
damit es eine gesetzliche pflicht zur
vorlage des erweiterten
führungszeugnisses im sport gibt für
betroffene und angehörige ist das nur
schwer zu verstehen
für expertinnen ist das führungszeugnis
aber auch nur ein baustein von vielen im
kampf gegen missbrauch
viel wichtiger den kindern zuhören
berichte von betroffenen wie matilda und
jakob helfen daraus zu lernen und so
kinder besser zu schützen
solange aber die vereine wegschauen
haben die täter es einfach jacobs
trainer wurde zu drei jahren und zehn
monaten haft verurteilt erst langsam
heilen jakob seelische wunden
wenn man ein kleines kind ist sollte man
es einfach sagen es kann nicht schlimmer
werden als es schon ist damit auch das
vorbei ist auch damit anderen auch mal
nach anderen kleinen kindern hilft wenn
man seinen eltern sagt und die der
verein sollte auch an sich dass viel
mehr kontrollieren damit sowas auch nie
wieder passieren kann
ihr habt ähnliche erfahrungen wie jakob
und mathilda machen müssen in unserer
infobox haben wir mehrere organisationen
verlinkt an die ihr euch wenden könnte